Speaking of Psychology is taking a summer break, so we're rerunning one of our favorite episodes from the past. In January, I talked to psychologists Drew Curtis and Christian Hart about pathological liars. What drives them? How you can recognize them and how you can protect yourself from being duped. We hope you enjoy this episode from the archives. Speaking of Psychology, we'll be back with new episodes on August 23rd. Thank you for listening. Almost everyone lies occasional. even if you consider yourself scrupulously honest, you've probably told the occasional fib.
Speaking of Psychology正在进行暑期休假，因此我们重播了过去最受欢迎的一期节目。在今年一月，我采访了心理学家德鲁·柯蒂斯（Drew Curtis）和克里斯蒂安·哈特（Christian Hart），探讨了病理性说谎者。是什么驱动了他们？你该如何识别他们，以及如何保护自己免受欺骗。我们希望你喜欢这期来自档案库的节目。Speaking of Psychology将于8月23日携新节目回归。感谢您的收听。几乎所有人偶尔都会说谎。即使你认为自己一丝不苟地诚实，你也可能说过善意的谎言。
But for a small percentage of people, lying isn't something that they do every once in a while. It's a way of life. Researchers have found that while most people tell between zero and two lies per day on average, the most prolific liars might tell five, ten, or even twenty. In recent weeks, the liar most in the news has been, newly elected Representative George Santos, whose long list of career embellishments, deceptions, and outright falsehoods came to light only after he won his seat. Santos appears to have made up college degrees, real estate holdings, even Jewish ancestry,
但对于一小部分人来说，说谎并不是偶尔为之的事，而是一种生活方式。研究发现，虽然大多数人平均每天说零到两个谎话，但最高产的说谎者可能会说五个、十个甚至二十个。最近几周，最受关注的说谎者是新当选的众议员乔治·桑托斯（George Santos），他那长长的履历镀金、欺骗和彻头彻尾的谎言清单，直到他赢得席位后才曝光。桑托斯似乎虚构了大学学位、房地产持有量，甚至犹太血统，
among his many other fabrications. So what drives big liars to lie, and are their motivations different from those other people who lie less frequently? Is pathological lying a mental health disorder? How common? is it, and are liars more prevalent in some professions like politics or sales, or those unfounded stereotypes? Are there differences in line between men and women, people of different social backgrounds, or among people who consider themselves religious? And finally, how can you recognize prolific liars in your life and protect yourself from being duped? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links
以及他许多其他的捏造。那么，是什么驱使这些大话精说谎，他们的动机与那些说谎频率较低的人不同吗？病理性说谎是一种心理健康障碍吗？它有多普遍？在政治或销售等某些行业中，说谎者是否更普遍，还是这只是毫无根据的刻板印象？在性别、不同社会背景的人或自认为有宗教信仰的人之间，说谎行为是否存在差异？最后，你如何在生活中识别高产的说谎者并保护自己免受欺骗？欢迎收听《心理学说话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。
between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. We have two guests today. The first is Dr. Drew Curtis, an associate professor of psychology and director of the master's and doctoral programs in counseling psychology at Angelo State University in San Angelo, Texas. Dr. Curtis is a licensed clinical psychologist who studies pathological lying and deception,
我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天有两位嘉宾。第一位是德鲁·柯蒂斯博士，他是德克萨斯州圣安杰洛安杰洛州立大学的心理学副教授兼咨询心理学硕士和博士项目主任。柯蒂斯博士是一位获得执照的临床心理学家，专门研究病理性说谎和欺骗，
particularly in the context of therapy and within health care professions, intimate relationships, and parental relationships. Our second guest is Dr. Christian Hart, a professor of psychology and director of the psychological science graduate program at Texas Women's University. He is an experimental psychologist
尤其是在治疗背景以及医疗保健专业、亲密关系和父母关系中的情况。我们的第二位嘉宾是克里斯蒂安·哈特博士，他是得克萨斯女子大学心理学教授兼心理科学研究生项目主任。他是一位实验心理学家，
who conducts research primarily on lying and deception. He is also the former president and current executive director of the Southwestern Psychological Association. Dr. Curtis and Hart are the co-authors of the book Pathological Lying, Theory, Research, and,
主要从事说谎和欺骗方面的研究。他还是西南心理协会（Southwestern Psychological Association）的前任主席和现任执行董事。柯蒂斯和哈特博士是《病理性说谎：理论、研究与实践》（Pathological Lying, Theory, Research, and Practice）一书的合著者，该书已于11月由APA图书出版。他们还在为大众写一本名为《大话精：心理科学告诉我们关于说谎的一切以及你如何避免被骗》（Big Liars, What Psychological Science Tells Us About Lying and How You Can Avoid Being Duped）的书，该书将于今年晚些时候由APA图书出版。非常感谢两位今天做客节目。非常高兴能来到这里。谢谢。谢谢邀请我们。
practice, which was published in November by APA books. They are also writing a book for the general public called Big Liars, What Psychological Science Tells Us About Lying and How You Can Avoid Be Duped, which will be published by APA books later this year. Thank you both for joining me today. It's a great pleasure to be here. Thank you. Thanks for having us. Great. Well, I started the introduction talking about how we all lie sometimes. So what is the difference between someone who just lies occasionally and a pathological liar? Is it a just how often they're lying or are the causes and motivations different? Dr. Curtis, you want to take that one?
太好了。好的，我在开场白中谈到了我们所有人有时都会说谎。那么，偶尔说谎的人与病理性说谎者之间有什么区别？这仅仅是关于他们说谎的频率，还是原因和动机有所不同？柯蒂斯博士，你想回答这个问题吗？
Yeah, absolutely. A lot of our work has really set out to ask that question among people who lie. Is there a clinical population? Is there a group that's different from people who might tell big liars? And essentially, we found and put forth theory and research that suggests there is. And so the criteria for pathological lying is people who tell an excessive. amount of lies, and that impairs their functioning, brings about distress, and poses some kind of risk of danger to themselves or others.
是的，当然。我们的很多工作实际上都是为了在说谎的人当中提出这个问题：是否存在一个临床群体？是否存在一个不同于那些可能会说大谎的人的群体？本质上，我们发现并提出了支持这一点的理论和研究。因此，病理性说谎的标准是：人们说了过量的谎言，这损害了他们的功能，带来了痛苦，并对他们自己或他人构成了某种危险。
Dr. Hart, let me ask you, what about the substance of the lies? When we're talking about a pathological liar, does that person tell different lies from just, you know, your average everyday garden variety liar? Well, there's not a lot of research on that topic. What we can gather from reading through the extensive case literature on pathological liars over the past century is that their lies tend to be somewhat varied. We can find some pretty clear cases where they're lying for some sort of financial motivation or financial gain. But one of the patterns that we tend to see perhaps more than you'd see in your typical everyday form of liar is lies that are aimed at bringing attention on oneself. And so that's probably the biggest distinction that we see.
哈特博士，请问谎言的实质呢？当我们谈论病理性说谎者时，这个人说的谎言是否与你身边普通、常见的说谎者不同？嗯，关于这个话题的研究并不多。通过阅读过去一个世纪关于病理性说谎者的广泛案例文献，我们可以了解到，他们的谎言往往有些多样化。我们可以发现一些非常清晰的案例，他们出于某种财务动机或财务利益而说谎。但我们倾向于看到的一种模式——也许比你在典型、日常形式的说谎者中看到的更多——是旨在引起人们对自己注意的谎言。所以这可能是我们看到的最大区别。
Pathological lying is not at the moment considered a mental health diagnosis, but you have both advocated for it to be added to the diagnostic and statistical manual of mental disorders. Why is that? Why do you want to see that? Well, I think it's got a robust history in clinical psychiatry. in psychology, a lot of our work and research on the literature, the most prominent psychiatrist, the times, late 1800s, early 1900s, have well documented the existence of pathological lying. And it's held different names, you know, like pseudologia, fantastica, mythomania. And so it's been well documented and tucked away by what we would say is the most prolific,
病理性说谎目前不被视为心理健康诊断，但你们两人都主张将其加入《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》。为什么会这样？为什么你们希望看到这一点？嗯，我认为它在临床精神病学中有坚实的历史。在心理学中，我们关于文献的大量工作和研究表明，那个时代最杰出的精神病学家（19世纪末、20世纪初）已经充分记录了病理性说谎的存在。它曾有过不同的名字，比如虚构狂（pseudologia fantastica）、神话狂（mythomania）。因此，它已被我们所说的历代最高产、最杰出的研究人员和临床医生很好地记录并保存了下来。
prominent researchers and clinicians throughout time. And so it's been recognized by them early on. And then some zeitgeist, essentially we've lost it throughout time. And so Chris and I have picked back up the gauntlet to look at this phenomena. Our research has corroborated based on that theory that there is a group of people who they're lying impairs their problems. and they're looking for some kind of treatment or some kind of help. So we've essentially just been very passionate to look at that.
因此，它很早就得到了他们的认可。但在某种时代精神下，随着时间的推移，我们基本上失去了它。所以克里斯和我重新拿起了接力棒来研究这个现象。我们的研究基于该理论证实，确实存在这样一群人，他们的说谎损害了他们的功能，他们正在寻求某种治疗或某种帮助。因此，我们本质上只是怀着极大的热情来研究这一点。
And our research has corroborated that it should be recognized as a diagnostic entity. How optimistic are you that you will succeed in getting the diagnosis included? And what's involved in that? There's a lot involved. And I guess I'm fairly optimistic. You know, the DSM, the American Psychiatric Association, has criteria for what, what needs to be done when submitting that. And there's task force and many intelligent people working hard to recognize these things that it's not maybe what some of the common public
我们的研究证实，它应该被公认为一个诊断实体。对于成功将该诊断纳入，你们有多乐观？这其中涉及什么？这涉及很多方面。我想我还是相当乐观的。你知道，DSM，即美国精神病学协会，对于提交该申请需要做的事情有标准。有一个工作组和许多聪明人在努力承认这些事情，这可能不像普通公众所认为的那样——
thinks is you just create a label to stigmatize people that it's a pretty lengthy process. And you have to show that there's the existence of something that people struggle with. And by providing a label, there's going to do more benefit than cause harm. And so I think not only our work, but work of others before us have demonstrated that there's more people who truly suffer from this and want help. And anecdotally, we've had people reach out to us via email saying, hey, I came across your work and I'm willing to travel across several states for treatment. I need help with this or significant other marriage is about to end and desperately need some help and can you help me? And it's unfortunate when we don't label it as a diagnostic entity,
你只是创造一个标签来污名化人们——这是一个相当漫长的过程。你必须证明人们所挣扎的事物的存在。并且通过提供一个标签，其带来的好处将大于造成的危害。因此，我认为不仅是我们的工作，还有我们之前其他人的工作，都表明有更多的人真正饱受其苦并寻求帮助。有趣的是，我们曾有人通过电子邮件联系我们，说：“嘿，我偶然看到了你的工作，我愿意跨越好几个州来接受治疗。我需要这方面的帮助，或者我的另一半婚姻即将结束，我迫切需要一些帮助，你能帮帮我吗？”不幸的是，当我们不把它贴上诊断实力的标签时，
At this point, we can't say we can formally call it anything and can't treat you accordingly. And so it would be beneficial then to the person who thinks that they have the disorder, that their insurance, for example, would cover the treatment. That's why we need this, right? That's one of the major reasons. You certainly want some insurance to cover treatment. And then another reason we want to recognize treatment is so researchers can start looking at what are the effective treatments, What are the empirically supported treatments that we can use to help people treat this in the most cost-effective and time-effective manner?
目前，我们不能说我们可以正式称它为什么，也不能对你进行相应的治疗。因此，对于认为自己患有这种障碍的人来说，这将是有益的，例如他们的保险将涵盖治疗费用。这就是为什么我们需要这个，对吧？这是主要原因之一。你当然希望某种保险能涵盖治疗。然后，我们希望承认治疗的另一个原因是，研究人员可以开始研究什么是有效的治疗方法，什么是我们可以用来帮助人们以最具成本效益和时间效益的方式治疗它的经验支持的治疗方法？
Dr. Hart, let me ask you, how common is pathological lying? Do we know what percentage of the population might qualify as a pathological liar? Yeah, answering that question's been a little problematic. Historically, researchers have looked at it, but they've looked at it within kind of netherly. narrow populations, populations that were having, you know, people in juvenile detention facilities and things like that, where obviously you might expect the rates to be considerably higher than the general population. Drew and I conducted a study that we published a few years ago where we tried to look at this. And based on the data we collected, we are showing rates around like 8 to 13%. percent, but a big caveat with that is we're collecting data from people on websites where they might
哈特博士，请问病理性说谎有多普遍？我们知道人口中有多少比例可能有资格被称为病理性说谎者吗？是的，回答这个问题一直有点问题。历史上，研究人员探讨过这个问题，但他们是在相当狭隘的人群中探讨的，比如青少年拘留所里的人等等，在这些地方，你显然可以预料到其比例会明显高于普通人口。德鲁和我几年前发表了一项研究，我们试图探讨这个问题。根据我们收集的数据，我们显示的比例大约在8%到13%左右，但这里有一个很大的警告，那就是我们是从一些网站上收集数据的，那里的人可能对此有特殊兴趣，并且可能更有可能有说谎的问题。
have some particular interest in this and might be more likely to have a problem with lying. So the more recent data that we've collected that we talk about in our book, I think we would put the rate at somewhere closer to 5%, if not even smaller than that. And one other thing there, you know, without having this as a diagnostic entity, labeled, we can't collect some of that data, too. So I think it's, you know, chicken or egg. Once we recognize pathological lying in the DSM, then as it's getting diagnosed, we can get more accurate data of what its prevalence is. Now, your book talks about differences in lying based on gender, social status, and some other demographic characteristics. Could you detail what you and
因此，我们在书中讨论的最新收集的数据，我认为我们会把这个比例定在接近5%的水平，甚至比这还要小。还有一件事，你知道，如果没有将此作为诊断实体进行标记，我们就无法收集其中的一些数据。所以我认为这是鸡生蛋还是蛋生鸡的问题。一旦我们在《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM）中承认病理性说谎，随着它的被诊断，我们就可以获得关于其流行率更准确的数据。现在，你们的书讨论了基于性别、社会地位和其他一些人口统计特征的说谎差异。你能详细说明你和其他研究人员在这些领域发现了什么吗？
other researchers have found in those areas? Sure. I'll talk a little bit about. that. With gender, we don't really see any gender differences in the frequency with which people lie. We do see some differences in the types of things that men and women lie about. For instance, women are more apt to tell lies that are relational in nature, whereas men are more apt to tell more kind of self-serving, selfish lies, I guess it would be the best way to describe them. We see some other traits and characteristics that are associated with more frequent lying. You mentioned religiosity at the beginning of this program. We actually just completed a fairly large study on that topic and didn't find much of a relationship at all between religiosity and lying.
当然。我来简单谈谈这个。在性别方面，我们在人们说谎的频率上并没有真正看到任何性别差异。我们在男女说谎的事情类型上确实看到了一些差异。例如，女性更有可能说出本质上与关系有关的谎言，而男性更有可能说出更具自利性、自私性的谎言，我想这是最好的描述方式。我们看到了其他一些与更频繁说谎相关的特质和特征。你在节目开始时提到了宗教信仰。我们实际上刚刚就这个话题完成了一项相当大的研究，发现在宗教信仰和说谎之间几乎没有什​​么关系。
Age is probably the biggest factor. If we look at the frequency of lying across the lifespan, lying seems to peak and late adolescence. So it kind of gradually increases throughout childhood, peaks and late adolescence, and then slowly declines across adulthood. So age is certainly the factor that we've identified so far that seems to be the strongest predictor of lying.
年龄可能是最大的因素。如果我们看整个生命周期中说谎的频率，说谎似乎在青春期后期达到顶峰。所以它在整个童年时期逐渐增加，在青春期后期达到顶峰，然后在成年期缓慢下降。因此，年龄无疑是我们迄今为止确定的最强说谎预测因素。
Then we also have personality traits. So your listeners are probably familiar with the, dark triad personality traits. You know, all these different malevolent personality traits, those tend to be associated with lying. Looking at kind of big five personality traits, we find that people who are low in agreeableness and high in neuroticism are more likely to lie.
然后我们还有人格特质。所以你的听众可能对暗黑三合型人格特质很熟悉。你知道，所有这些不同的恶毒人格特质都与说谎有关。从大五人格特质来看，我们发现宜人度低、神经质高的人更有可能说谎。
And then finally, people who have low self-esteem are much more inclined to lie than those who have higher levels of self-esteem. So I think the research shows, that lying in people starts around age three, right? That's when children first figure out that they can sort of fib to mom and dad. But at what age does pathological lying start? Do you know? Our work has largely suggested the onset, primarily in adolescence, late childhood adolescence. And so one of the studies that Chris and I with Dr. Victoria Tower are currently working on is looking at an adolescent sample to look at some more specific factors of ideology.
最后，自卑的人比自尊水平高的人更有倾向说谎。所以我认为研究表明，人们从三岁左右开始说谎，对吧？那是孩子们第一次发现他们可以向爸爸妈妈撒点小谎的时候。但是病理性说谎从什么年龄开始？你知道吗？我们的工作在很大程度上表明其发病主要在青春期，即儿童晚期至青春期。因此，克里斯和我与维多利亚·托尔（Victoria Tower）博士目前正在进行的一项研究之一，就是观察青少年样本，以寻找病因的一些更具体因素。
So looking at executive functioning within that group and looking at the onset. So digging a little deeper into adolescence. There is a stereotype of dishonest politicians with George Santos being a very extreme example right now, although not the only one, or other types of snake oil salesmen. Is there a kernel of truth to that? Are pathological liars more common in some professions than others? We haven't seen any evidence of that. When we look at lying generally, we see that people tend to lie when they have a motivation or an incentive to lie.
因此，研究该群体内的执行功能并观察发病情况。从而更深入地探讨青春期。有一种关于不诚实政客的刻板印象，乔治·桑托斯（George Santos）目前就是一个非常极端的例子，尽管不是唯一的例子，或者其他类型的江湖郎中。这其中包含核心的真实性吗？病理性说谎者在某些行业中比其他行业更常见吗？我们没有看到任何这方面的证据。当我们笼统地看说谎时，我们发现当人们有说谎的动机或诱因时，他们往往会说谎。
And those motivations and incentives are more common in some professions than others, certainly. in sales and in politics, it's very difficult to be entirely honest and effectively do one's job. And so taking politics as an example, we can see that people who go into politics don't seem to be any less honest, typically, than people in the general population. However, what we see is that politicians who lie more are much more likely to be reelected. And so what it suggests is that the people who go into politics are probably no less honest than you and me, but there's something about the profession that pushes them in a direction where they might have to conceal certain truths that might cause them to lose some of their favorability with the public and might push them to, to fabricate information and exaggerate and perhaps even conceal the truth and lie. Well, are pathological liars aware that they are lying or do they tend to believe what they're
这些动机和诱因在某些行业中肯定比其他行业更常见。在销售和政治中，要完全诚实并有效地完成工作是非常困难的。因此，以政治为例，我们可以看到，从事政治的人通常似乎并不比普通大众更不诚实。然而，我们看到的是，说谎更多的政客更有可能再次当选。因此，这表明从政的人可能并不比你我更不诚实，但这个行业的某些特性将他们推向了一个方向，在这个方向上他们可能不得不隐瞒某些真相，这些真相可能会导致他们失去公众的一些好感，并可能促使他们捏造信息、夸大其词，甚至可能隐瞒真相和说谎。好吧，病理性说谎者是否意识到他们在说谎，还是他们倾向于相信自己所说的话？他们真的理解他们谎言的后果吗？
saying? And do they really grasp the consequences of their falsehoods? Our research has indicated. Different research asking about questions of awareness or even some assessment research we've done where we've brought people in conducting psychological evaluations one-on-one. You know, many, for the definition, let me back up, the definition of lying is an intentional act. So you're intentionally trying to make someone believe something you don't believe to be true. And that definition is important for us because it helps distinguish delusion or aspects of psychopathology of psychosis where someone's delusional, where they're actually
我们的研究表明了这一点。不同的研究提出了关于意识的问题，或者甚至是我们做过的一些评估研究，我们将人们带进来一对一地进行心理评估。你知道，对于这个定义，请允许我退一步说，说谎的定义是一种蓄意行为。所以你是有意让别人相信一些你认为不是真的事情。这个定义对我们来说很重要，因为它有助于将妄想或精神病理学的精神病方面区分开来，在这些方面，有人有妄想，他们实际上
intending to lie. And so with that awareness, you know, many pathological liars, are aware and they are intentionally lying. Now sometimes, you know, sometimes they may say it's for an innocuous reason or sometimes they may say, I don't know why I said what I said or, you know, someone ask you, what's your favorite cereal when you say weedies even though it's Cheerios? And you're like, well, why'd you lie about that? That's seemingly innocuous. Why would you do that? They may say something like, I'm not sure why it did. And then it, you know, it can build up from that, you know, becoming this monstrous lies to cover lies to cover lies. But many of the times that they are aware and in the moment they'll say doing so almost as a
打算说谎。因此，对于这种意识，你知道，许多病理性说谎者是知道的，他们是在故意说谎。现在有时，你知道，有时他们可能会说这是出于无害的原因，或者有时他们可能会说，“我不知道我为什么要说我所说的话”或者，“你知道，当有人问你，你最喜欢什么麦片，你说是惠笛鸟（Wheeties），尽管它是全麦甜圈（Cheerios）。”然后你会想，好吧，你为什么要为那个说谎？这似乎是无害的。你为什么要那样做？他们可能会说一些类似“我不确定我为什么要这么做”的话。然后它，你知道的，可以从那里积累起来，你知道，变成这个可怕的谎言来掩盖谎言来掩盖谎言。但在很多时候，他们是知道的，并且在当下他们会说这样做几乎就像是一种
compulsion reduces the anxiety and they feel momentarily relief. But then sometime afterwards, you know, maybe hours, maybe the next day or two, that's where the remorse and the guilt comes in where they're thinking, why did I lie about weedies? Why didn't I just say I like Cheerios? or why did I lie about my favorite band or song? Why did I do that? And that's where the guilt and remorse will be present. Are pathological liars more likely to be dishonest in other ways?
强迫症，减少了焦虑，他们感到瞬间的解脱。但在这之后的某个时候，你知道，可能是几小时后，可能是第二天或两天后，这就是悔恨和内疚出现的地方，他们会想：“我为什么要为惠笛鸟说谎？我为什么不说我喜欢全麦甜圈呢？或者我为什么要为我最喜欢的乐队或歌曲说谎？我为什么要这样做？”这就是内疚和悔恨存在的地方。病理性说谎者在其他方面更有可能不诚实吗？
For example, were they more likely to cheat on their taxes or have extramarital affairs? Or is lying its own thing? And it's just a separate type of dishonesty. That's another area where there's not much research. that's been carried out specific on pathological liars that would allow to answer that question. However, if we look at lying more broadly, what we have found in our research is that if people tend to tell one type of lie or behave dishonestly in one type of way, they tend to lie and be dishonest in other ways as well.
例如，他们更有可能在税收上作弊或有婚外情吗？还是说谎是它自己的一回事？它只是一种独立的不诚实行为？这是另一个领域，没有对病理性说谎者进行过多的具体研究，无法回答这个问题。然而，如果我们更广泛地看说谎，我们在研究中发现的是，如果人们倾向于说某一种谎言或在某一类方式上表现得不诚实，他们也倾向于在其他方面说谎和不诚实。
So, for example, we've measured various categories of lies from benevolent white lies to malicious lies, to kind of vindictive lies. And what we find is that people who tell a lot of one type of lie tend to tell a lot of the other types of lies as well. So there's these strong correlations between the different types of dishonesty. So what this suggests to us is that for the most part, if we're categorizing someone as being a prolific liar, they're probably going to be lying across domains. However, we also make a point in our upcoming book that some people are deceptive in specific niche areas. And so we're talking about occupations a little bit ago.
因此，例如，我们测量了从善意的善意谎言到恶意的谎言，再到某种报复性的谎言的各种类别的谎言。我们发现，说了大量某一种谎言的人，也倾向于说大量的其他类型的谎言。因此，不同类型的不诚实之间存在着这些强烈的相关性。所以这向我们表明，在大多数情况下，如果我们把某人归类为高产的说谎者，他们很可能在各个领域都在说谎。然而，我们在即将出版的书里也指出，有些人在特定的细分领域具有欺骗性。所以我们刚才讨论了一点职业。
So someone might be in a position where they find themselves recurrently lying at the workplace, either to deal with a problematic boss or to sell products to customers or what have you, but then might be fairly honest with their family. And so we can have certainly examples of people who have these niche areas where they're prolific liars and honest in other areas. but by and large, dishonest people tend to be dishonest across the different domains of their lives. There's a documentary that just launched on Netflix about Bernie Madoff, who pulled off. The biggest investment Ponzi scheme that we have ever seen, even bigger than the similar scheme we're seeing right now,
因此，某人可能会发现自己经常在工作场所说谎，要么是为了对付有问题的老板，要么是为了向客户推销产品诸如此类，但在对家人时可能相当诚实。因此，我们当然可以有这样的例子，这些人拥有这些高产说谎的细分领域，而在其他领域则是诚实的。但总的来说，不诚实的人往往在他们生活的各个领域都是不诚实的。Netflix刚推出了一部关于伯纳德·麦道夫（Bernie Madoff）的纪录片，他策划了
apparently by a cryptocurrency dealer Sam Bankman-Fried. These types of frauds where you rob Peter to pay Paul, as they say, are arguably a form of, of lying, would you view people who perpetrate these types of frauds as pathological liars, even though, at least in these cases, these individuals appeared to be honest in other areas of their lives? Yeah, I think if we're going to talk about whether they're pathological liars or not, I'll invite your attention back to the way that we've been characterizing pathological lying in our book, and the way we characterize it is these are people who proliferate.
我们见过的最大的投资庞氏骗局，甚至比我们现在看到的类似骗局还要大，显然是一个加密货币交易员萨姆·班克曼-弗里德（Sam Bankman-Fried）策划的。这些拆东墙补西墙的诈骗可以说是谎言的一种形式，你会认为实施这些诈骗的人是病理性说谎者吗，尽管至少在这些情况下，这些人在他们生活的其他领域似乎是诚实的？是的，我想如果我们来讨论他们是否是病理性说谎者，我会请大家回想一下我们在书中对病理性说谎的描述方式，我们将其描述为：这些人是高产地
liifically lie, but the lying causes distress and dysfunction in their lives and so forth. And so when we look at people like Bernie Madoff and other scammers and fraudsters, I think it's probably in many cases we're looking at something more along the lines of an antisocial personality disorder rather than what Drew and I would conceptualize as pathological liars. So these are people who are certainly doing a lot of lying, but their lying is very specific with this malicious intent to manipulate and take advantage of others with this callous disregard, lack of remorse and so forth. Does pathological line tend to be a separate disorder, or is it associated with other disorders
说谎，但这种说谎给他们的生活带来了痛苦和功能障碍等等。因此，当我们看到像伯纳德·麦道夫和其他骗子和诈骗犯这样的人时，我认为在很多情况下，我们看到的事情更类似于反社会人格障碍，而不是德鲁和我所概念化的病理性说谎者。所以这些人当然做了很多说谎，但他们的说谎非常具体，带有操纵和利用他人的恶意意图，伴随着冷酷的漠视、缺乏悔恨等等。病理性说谎倾向于成为一种独立的障碍，还是与具有更正式、公认诊断的其他障碍相关？
that have, say, a more formal, recognized diagnosis at this point? Well, that's, you know, that's a great question that many times comes with some clinicians. One of the studies Chris and I did was looking specifically at psychotherapist. looking at licensed psychologist. And, you know, when there is no diagnostic label, what do you do? So we found a number of our research participants who are licensed psychologists indicated they had come across individuals who are pathological liars, and they believed them to be pathological liars.
嗯，这是一个好问题，许多临床医生经常会遇到这个问题。克里斯和我做的一项研究是专门针对心理治疗师的。针对有执照的心理学家。而且，你知道，当没有诊断标签时，你该怎么办？因此，我们发现许多作为研究参与者的有执照心理学家表示，他们曾遇到过病理性说谎者，并且他们认为这些人是病理性说谎者。
And so what they ended up doing was to provide some treatment, needed some diagnostic category. Many times they would give a personality disorder diagnosis. And so that happens. And sometimes, you know, there may be rebuttals or arguments against some of the work Chris and I are doing from others saying, well, that pathological lying is just a symptom of something else like a personality disorder. It's a symptom of antisocial personality disorder. Some of the work, though, we've done in our lab assessing individuals giving them psychological evaluations, we find that the pathological lying sample, they've done. don't fit the diagnostic criteria for antisocial personality disorder. Many of them haven't had any kind of run-ins with the law or any kind of forensic complications. Many times there's lack of, there's no aggression.
所以他们最终做的是，为了提供一些治疗，需要某种诊断类别。很多时候，他们会给出人格障碍的诊断。所以这种情况会发生。有时，你知道，其他人可能会对克里斯和我的某些工作提出反驳或争论，说“嗯，那个病理性说谎只是诸如人格障碍之类的事情的一个症状。它是反社会人格障碍的一个症状。”然而，我们在实验室中对个人进行评估、给他们进行心理评估的一些工作发现，病理性说谎样本并没有符合反社会人格障碍的诊断标准。他们中的许多人没有任何违法行为或任何类型的法医并发症。很多时候缺乏攻击性。
So aggression is another criteria of antisocial personality disorder. Many times, as I said earlier, they tend to feel remorse. And so that doesn't fit the same picture as antisocial personality disorder or psychopathy. And so separating that is very important for clinicians. It's also good for people to understand who might be suffering from pathological lying where they line up. And then Charles D.K. from Yale suggested pathological lying as well being considered for the DSM as a diagnostic entity. And under that specifiers of factitious disorder. And so Chris and I, based on our research, would agree with Charles D.K., suggesting pathological lying being the overarching diagnosis, and then subtypes and specifiers like factitious disorder or pseudologia fantastica.
所以攻击性是反社会人格障碍的另一个标准。很多时候，正如我之前所说，他们往往会感到悔恨。这与反社会人格障碍或精神病态（psychopathy）的画面不符。因此，对临床医生来说，将这一点区分开来非常重要。这也适合那些可能患有病理性说谎并想知道自己处于什么位置的人去了解。来自耶鲁大学的查尔斯·D·K（Charles D.K.）也建议将病理性说谎作为诊断实体考虑纳入DSM。并在其下归入人为障碍（factitious disorder）的说明符。因此，克里斯和我，根据我们的研究，会同意查尔斯·D·K的看法，即建议病理性说谎作为总括诊断，然后是亚型和说明符，如人为障碍或虚构狂（pseudologia fantastica）。
Are there effective treatments for pathological lying? Can people get better with therapy if they're motivated to do so? And if so, what types of therapy work? Well, as a clinician, I tend to hold an optimistic view of change for people. And so that's where I land. You know, we run in the same problem with, you know, that's a great question. Can people get better? And so we go back to the same problem when we don't have a formal diagnosis for pathological lying. We don't have research-based treatments to see what is most effective. And will these things be helpful? So that poses a problem for us. But, in our book, we talk about some research we did with therapists and then our own inferences of treatments. And largely therapists and ourselves, we think that cognitive behavioral therapy would be highly effective to treat and work with people who suffer from pathological line. And so essentially what you can do is help people become aware of their cognitions. What's the function of their lives? which situations might they have a higher proclivity to tell lives, and typically that's going to be
是否有针对病理性说谎的有效治疗方法？如果患者有动力去改善，他们能通过治疗好转吗？如果是这样，什么样的治疗方法有效？嗯，作为一名临床医生，我对人们的改变往往抱有乐观的看法。这就是我的立场。你知道，我们遇到了同样的问题，这是一个好问题：人们能好转吗？因此，当我们没有关于病理性说谎的正式诊断时，我们又回到了同样的问题。我们没有基于研究的治疗方法来观察什么是最有效的。这些事情会有帮助吗？因此，这给我们带来了问题。但是，在我们的书中，我们讨论了我们对治疗师所做的一些研究，以及我们对治疗自己的推论。在很大程度上，治疗师和我们自己认为，认知行为疗法（CBT）对于治疗和处理患有病理性说谎的人将是非常有效的。因此，本质上你可以做的是帮助人们意识到他们的认知。他们谎言的功能是什么？
relationally. So being aware of those situations, and then a lot of behavioral treatments. So some of these we call differential reinforcement of other behavior or habit reversal training. Essentially, the idea is you become aware of your behaviors, become aware of when you lie, and not give that attention, rather reinforce honesty behaviors. And that may mean even when honesty doesn't necessarily lead to a good consequence. You know, if you tell someone that ask you, do you like my new haircut? My son just got a new haircut and he doesn't like it too well. So if you get asked that, you know, you could lie to make someone feel good. Oh, it looks great. Or you could be honest and, you know, there's some consequences there.
哪些情况下他们说谎的倾向可能更高，通常那将是关系方面的。因此，要意识到这些情况，以及许多行为疗法。其中一些我们称之为其他行为的差异强化（differential reinforcement of other behavior）或习惯逆转训练（habit reversal training）。本质上，这个想法是你意识到自己的行为，意识到你什么时候说谎，并且不要给予那种关注，而是强化诚实的行为。这甚至可能意味着当诚实不一定带来好的结果时。你知道，如果你告诉一个问你“你觉得我的新发型怎么样？”的人——我儿子刚剪了个新发型，他不太喜欢。所以如果你被问到那个，你知道，你可以说谎让某人感觉良好。“哦，它看起来棒极了。”或者你可以诚实，你知道，这会有一些后果。
But even with pathological lying, we'd have to reinforce telling the truth, even if the consequence may not be the most desirable for the person. But isn't there kind of a catch-22, though, for the therapist? Because you're dealing with somebody whose problem is lying. So how do you know that your patient is telling you the truth? Yeah, that's a great question. And that kind of fueled a lot of Chris and I our interest in this early on, in our work early on and just deception within therapy. So therapy rests on the assumption of honesty, that all that we do
但即使对于病理性说谎，我们也必须强化说实话，即使其后果可能对这个人来说不是最理想的。但是，对于治疗师来说，难道没有一种进退维谷的困境吗？因为你在和一个问题是说谎的人打交道。那么你怎么知道你的病人对你说的就是实话呢？是的，这是一个好问题。这在早期推动了克里斯和我对此的大量兴趣，在我们的早期工作中以及在治疗中的欺骗行为。所以治疗建立在诚实的假设之上，即我们在谈话治疗中所做的一切
and talk therapy is that we assume our patients are honest. One of the things with pathological lying to understand is even though they tell lies much more frequently than most people, they're not lying all the time about everything. And so even in some of our assessment studies, the question I would ask people at the end is what have you lied to me today about? And many of them would indicate nothing. Why not? You know, why haven't you lied? And many of them would say answers like, well, this is a real struggle from me. I'm hoping to advance science. If you learn from me, you can help out other people. So they're not lying all the time about everything. And I think that's important to note. The other thing to note there, too, is I think very important for therapist is when,
和谈话都是基于我们假设患者是诚实的。关于病理性说谎需要理解的一件事是，尽管他们比大多数人更频繁地说谎，但他们并不是一直在对所有事情说谎。因此，即使在我们的一些评估研究中，我最后问人们的问题是：“你今天对我说了什么谎？”他们中的许多人会表示“没有”。“为什么不呢？你知道，你为什么没有说谎？”他们中的许多人会给出这样的答案：“嗯，这对我是个真正的挣扎。我希望推动科学发展。如果你从我这里学到东西，你就可以帮助其他人。”所以他们并不是一直在对所有事情说谎。我认为这一点值得注意。需要注意的另一件事是，我认为对治疗师非常重要的是，当
someone lies to us, we typically take it personal and get defensive. And that typically isn't productive in therapy. So the way you overcome that is kind of know your stance, become non-defensive, and use that to try to understand with a patient, you know, what's the function of this lie? Are you wanting me to give you praise? Are you wanting me to think of you in a certain light? Are you trying to form a certain impression? do you not want me to think poorly of you?
有人对我们说谎时，我们通常会把它当作针对个人的事情并进行防卫。这在治疗中通常是没有成效的。因此，克服这一点的方法是了解你的立场，保持不防卫，并试着与患者一起理解，你知道，这个谎言的功能是什么？你是想让我夸奖你吗？你是想让我以某种眼光看你吗？你是想树立某种印象吗？你是不希望我把你看得很糟吗？
But if you start asking those questions, I think that that would breed more trust and compassion for the person to lean in and understand them. And that's why Chris and I really wrote the book we wrote, was to lean in and understand pathological lying much deeper rather than just turning away and saying, these are crazies that we can never understand, but people who are suffering and want help.
但是如果你开始问这些问题，我认为这将为这个人培养更多的信任和同情心，让他们倾身并理解他们。这就是为什么克里斯和我真正写了我们所写的那本书，是为了倾身并更深入地理解病理性说谎，而不是简单地转身说，这些是我们永远无法理解的疯子，而是那些正在受苦并寻求帮助的人。
What about group therapy as a treatment? And doesn't that give you the option, the opportunity for other people to sort of call out liars as opposed to having the therapist have to do that? Yeah, yeah, we suggest group therapy. And I'm laughing because you're absolutely right. You know, one of the ways that group therapy works is the therapist doesn't have to call out the patient. So the brilliance of any kind of interpersonal work is other members in the group can say, hey, you know, BS, you just lied. And that works so well in a group therapy context because it's not about patient client opposing each other. Rather, it's about other people are seeing this thing in you too.
小组治疗作为一种治疗方法怎么样？难道这不给你提供了一个选项、一个让其他人指出说谎者的机会，而不是让治疗师必须这样做吗？是的，是的，我们建议小组治疗。我在笑，因为你完全说对了。你知道，小组治疗起作用的方式之一是治疗师不必指出患者的错误。任何形式的人际工作的妙处在于，小组中的其他成员可以说：“嘿，你知道吗，废话，你刚刚说谎了。”这在小组治疗的背景下效果非常好，因为这不关乎患者和客户相互对立。相反，这是关于其他人也在你身上看到了这一点。
Dr. Hart, let me throw this one at you. How can people recognize and protect themselves from pathological liars? Are there telltale signs or particular personality traits of the most hardened pathological liars? I think we know that we're very bad at tell. telling when people are lying to us. And pathological liars, I mean, how do we suss them out as opposed to just an everyday liar? Yeah, it's a perplexing problem. In your correct, people are really poor lie detectors.
哈特博士，让我把这个抛给你。人们如何识别并保护自己免受病理性说谎者的侵害？对于最顽固的病理性说谎者，是否有明显的迹象或特定的人格特质？我想我们知道我们非常不擅长辨别人们是否在对我们说谎。对于病理性说谎者，我的意思是，我们如何将他们与普通说谎者区分开来？是的，这是一个令人困惑的问题。你说得对，人们真的是很差劲的谎言探测器。
If we look at people's ability to detect when people are lying versus being honest in laboratory studies, what we find is that people perform at only slightly above chance levels. That is, they'd be almost as effective. just flipping a coin, guessing whether someone's is guessing whether someone's being honest or not. And it really kind of gets back to the fact that we are a cooperative species. And so we tend to have what's referred to as a truth default. That is, we just assume people are being honest when they speak. And so we tend not to be on guard for deception.
如果我们观察实验室研究中人们检测他人说谎与诚实的能力，我们发现人们的表现仅略高于随机水平。也就是说，他们的效果几乎和抛硬币、猜测某人是在说实话还是不是差不多。这实际上归根于这样一个事实，即我们是一个合作的物种。因此，我们往往具有所谓的“真相默认值”（truth default）。也就是说，当人们说话时，我们只是假设他们是诚实的。因此，我们往往不会对欺骗保持警惕。
So when we look at how people actually detect lying, it's not by, you know, seeing that someone's looking askance or they're, you know, fidgeting with their hands or shuffling their feet, but rather we detect people or lying by hearing them say things that conflict with factual information we actually know. Or we find out they're lying by gathering additional information from third parties, or in some cases people just feel guilty and confess. And so when we look at how could we avoid being duped by pathological liars, my answer would be it's the same way we avoid being duped by everyone else. And primarily what that is is we are sensitive to signs of trustworthiness. When we meet people, we walk in with usually a fairly trusting attitude,
因此，当我们观察人们实际上是如何检测谎言时，并不是通过看到某人斜眼看，或者他们摆弄双手或拖着双脚，而是通过听到他们说的话与我们实际知道的事实信息相冲突来检测人们在说谎。或者我们通过从第三方收集更多信息发现他们在说谎，或者在某些情况下，人们只是感到内疚并坦白。因此，当我们考虑如何避免被病理性说谎者欺骗时，我的回答是，这与我们避免被其他人欺骗的方式相同。最主要的是，我们对可信度的迹象很敏感。当我们遇到人时，我们通常带着相当信任的态度走进去，
but we only trust people so far. And so, for example, if we know that someone has an incentive to lie to us, an incentive to manipulate us, we're going to be more on guard and more apt to detect their dishonesty. Likewise, if we can rely on people's reputations, if I know nothing about your reputation, I'm going to be a little bit more suspicious of things you say than if I know you quite well and know you to have a reputation as being an honest person. But generally, when we've talked to people about pathological liars that they have met or known and how they knew those people were lying. What we find is they say that the people say unbelievable things, that is, they're making claims that just don't seem likely to have actually
但我们对人的信任也是有限度的。因此，例如，如果我们知道某人有动机对我们说谎，有动机操纵我们，我们会更加警惕，并且更容易发现他们的不诚实。同样，如果我们能够依靠人们的声誉，如果我对你的声誉一无所知，我对你所说的事情会比我非常了解你并知道你有诚实声誉时更加怀疑。但总的来说，当我们与遇到过或认识病理性说谎者的人交谈，并了解他们是如何知道那些人在说谎时，我们发现他们说那些人说的话令人难以置信，也就是说，他们提出了根本不可能真正发生的声称，或者他们说的话前后矛盾。因此，例如，你知道，你刚才提到了乔治·桑托斯的案子，我相信他曾表示他的母亲在9-11袭击中丧生，然后又声称她是在十年后去世的。因此，当我们看到信息不一致时，这可能是一个线索。所以实际上我们正在做的是寻找连贯性。我们在寻找证据，我们在寻找一个人的声誉状态。所有这些结合在一起可以告诉我们应该对谁保持怀疑，也许对谁可以更信任。那么，你们即将出版的关于说谎的新书与我们APA已经出版的那本有什么不同呢？
happened, or they say things that are inconsistent. And so, for example, you know, you were mentioning the case of George Santos, I believe he indicated his mother died during the 9-11 attacks, and then later claimed that she had died, you know, a decade later. And so when we see inconsistency and information, that can be a cue. So really what we're doing is we're looking for coherence. We're looking for proof and we're looking for the reputational status of a person. All of those together can inform us of who we should be suspicious of and maybe who we can be more trusting of. So how will your upcoming book online differ from the one that we at APA have already published?
我发现那本书相当通俗易懂。我的意思是，我认为你不需要成为心理学家去阅读它，但你的新书里会有什么内容呢？嗯，谢谢你对第一本书的美意。我们希望能让它通俗易懂。但第二本书的不同之处在于，它不关注病理性说谎者。我们当然会讨论病理性说谎者。但除了病理性说谎者之外，我们还会关注那些高产说谎或说极其严重的谎言的人。所以，你知道，在很多情况下，我们可能在讨论那些表现出精神病态、反社会人格障碍或其他人格障碍迹象的人。
I found that to be quite accessible. I mean, I don't think you need to be a psychologist to read that, but what's going to be in your new book? Well, thanks for the kind words about the first book. We were hoping to make it accessible. But the difference in the second book is it doesn't focus on pathological liars. We certainly address pathological liars. But we look at people who lie prolifically or tell extremely consequential lies aside from pathological liars. So, you know, we're probably talking in a lot of cases about people who exhibit signs of psychopathy or antisocial personality disorder or other personality disorders.
我发现那本书挺容易理解的。我的意思是，我觉得读那本书并不需要具备心理学背景，不过你的新书会讲些什么呢？嗯，谢谢你对第一本书的夸奖。我们当时就希望能让它通俗易懂。但第二本书的不同之处在于，它并不专注于病理性说谎者。我们当然也会讨论病理性说谎者，但除了病理性说谎者之外，我们还会关注那些频繁说谎或者说了极其严重谎言的人。所以，你知道，在很多情况下，我们讨论的可能是在很大程度上表现出精神病态、反社会人格障碍或其他人格障碍迹象的人。
But really what we're interested in is the people who tell the consequential lies or the extremely frequent lies where they develop a reputation as being a dishonest person. And we're looking at how do they develop into these types of big liars? What are the consequences of their big lying? on themselves, on the people around them, and on society more broadly. And then we examine ways for cultivating honesty, both in ourselves and the people around us. And we talk to a certain degree about different tactics we can use to avoid being duped. So what are you both working on now? And what are the big questions that you're trying to answer at the moment? One of the things, I kind of mentioned earlier that Chris and I with Victoria Tower are working on,
但实际上我们感兴趣的是那些说出重大谎言或极其频繁说谎的人，他们因此落得了不诚实之人的名声。我们正在研究他们是如何演变成这类超级说谎者的？他们的大谎言会带来什么后果？对他们自己、对周围的人以及对更广泛的社会。然后，我们探讨培养诚实的方法，无论是在我们自己身上还是在我们周围的人身上。我们在一定程度上讨论了我们可以用来避免被骗的不同策略。那么你们两个现在都在做什么？你们目前试图回答的重大问题是什么？其中有一件事，我之前提到过，克里斯和我与维多利亚·托尔正在合作，
digging deeper into the etiology. So onset and cause of pathological lying, you know, the big broad question all psychologists have, nature, nurture, how much of one or the other. And as a clinician, most clinicians want to understand etiology. So we're really digging into those questions that we don't know about how it develops and how it makes. and then are there certain developmental trajectories that lead to a path of pathological lying compared to normative lying? So that's where we're focusing a little more specifically right now with some of our research. Chris, as you want to add to that? Yeah, we're also doing a little bit of work on the motivators, what drives people to lie, especially what drives people to lie to excess.
深入研究病理性说谎的病因。也就是病理性说谎的发作和起因，你知道的，所有心理学家都有的那个宏大而广泛的问题：先天还是后年，各自占了多少比例。作为一名临床医生，大多数临床医生都想了解病因。所以我们真的在深入研究那些我们尚不了解的关于它是如何发展和形成的未知问题，然后，与正常说谎相比，是否存在某些导致病理性说谎道路的发育轨迹？这就是我们目前通过部分研究更加具体关注的领域。克里斯，你想补充点什么吗？是的，我们还在做一些关于动机的工作，是什么驱使人们说谎，尤其是是什么驱使人们过度说谎。
And so we can see that people don't lie randomly. They don't lie for no reason at all. If we see someone lying, there's some sort of an incentive that's driving them to lie. But we also, most people are balanced that with some disincentives to lie. So, you know, if you are caught lying, it's certainly going to affect you reputational, which is going to hamper your ability to have the types of social relationships you desire. But then we also each have a moral. sense of self that seems to curb most of our bad behavior. So we don't refrain from bad
因此我们可以看到，人们不是随机说谎的。他们不会无缘无故地说谎。如果我们看到有人在说谎，一定有某种动机在驱使他们说谎。但我们同时也发现，大多数人在说谎时，也会受到一些不利因素的制衡。所以，你知道的，如果你被抓到说谎，这肯定会影响你的声誉，从而阻碍你建立你所期望的社会关系的能力。但除此之外，我们每个人都有一个道德自我感，它似乎能抑制我们的大部分不良行为。所以我们不克制不良
behavior simply because we're worried about getting caught. We refrain from it because we don't want to view ourselves as being awful people. And so trying to understand those complex motivations that are behind people's decisions to lie, especially lie prolifically or remain honest as another area of interest of ours. And then one other thing more recently, Chris has led, is developing an instrument to assess pathological lying more fully, an instrument that researchers and clinicians can use so we can assess pathological lying to answer some of these questions, get a little more accurate prevalence rate and study these things. Well, I want to thank you both for joining me today.
行为不仅仅是因为担心被抓。我们克制行为是因为我们不想把自己视为糟糕的人。因此，试图理解人们决定说谎背后的复杂动机，尤其是频繁说谎或保持诚实的动机，是我们感兴趣的另一个领域。此外，最近还有另一件事，由克里斯主导，即开发一种更全面地评估病理性说谎的工具，这是一个研究人员和临床医生可以使用的工具，以便我们能够评估病理性说谎，从而回答其中一些问题，获得更准确的患病率并研究这些事情。嗯，我要感谢你们俩今天能来。
I've found our conversation really interesting and enlightening, and I mean that honestly. We appreciate it. We enjoy it as well, honestly. Thank you so much for having us. It's been a great pleasure talking with you. You can find a link to pre-order the book Big Liars on APA's website, www.org, and just go there and search for Big Liars. Or if you can't wait, you can order their current book, Pathological Lying, Theory, Research, and Practice, also on the APA website. For previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology, visit us at speakingofpsychology.org, or you can find us on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you heard, please leave us a review. If you have comments
我发现我们的对话非常有趣且富有启发性，我是真心这么觉得的。我们非常感激。我们也乐在其中，说真的。非常感谢邀请我们。与您交谈是一件非常愉快的事。您可以在美国心理协会（APA）的网站 www.org 上找到预订新书《大说谎者》的链接，只需访问该网站并搜索《Big Liars》。或者如果您等不及了，您也可以订购他们目前出版的书籍《病理性说谎：理论、研究与实践》，同样在 APA 网站上。有关《心理学播客》之前的节目，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org，或者您可以在苹果、Stitcher 或任何您获取播客的平台上找到我们。如果您喜欢我们节目的内容，请给我们留下评论。如果您有意见
or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condiyan. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或对未来播客的想法，您可以发送电子邮件至 Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。《心理学播客》由李·韦纳曼制作。我们的音频编辑是克里斯·康迪扬。感谢您收听美国心理协会的节目。我是金·米尔斯。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。